I'm at the Arecibo Observatory in Puerto
Rico it is one of the world's largest
radio telescopes with a dish 300 meters
across I had seen pictures and video of
this before I came here but honestly the
the sheer scale is impossible to get
across on camera it is massive for 50
years it's been listening to the sky and
one day it might just save the world
our Siva has been part of discovering
the large-scale structure of the
universe we've discovered prebiotic
molecules in distant galaxies that the
first millisecond pulsar the first
exoplanets the big one which everyone
knows about is the Nobel Prize for a
discovery of the binary pulsar and the
way that it orbit decayed exactly as
predicted by general relativity there's
50 years of discoveries here I could
talk for 50 years on discoveries of
Arecibo one of the most incredible
things about the observatory is this the
suspended platform that I'm standing on
right now this entire colossal structure
is suspended in the air on cables like
suspension bridge there are no pillars
underneath holding this up and getting
in the way all this weight is being
carried by the three concrete towers
around the dish and this platform isn't
static big parts of it move the
telescope by going a short way north and
south can actually see about 1/3 of a
total sky from here the main bowler of
this dish is spherical the complication
though is a spherical mirror doesn't
have a point of focus like hyperbolic
mirror which were used to with big
optical telescopes and most big radio
telescopes and so in order to get the
signal to a focus the Gregorian dome
contains two smaller reflectors these
smaller reflectors actually bring
everything to a point focus and that
means in the Gregorian dome we can have
much wider band receivers and cover from
point three gigahertz up to 10 gigahertz
in frequency
iris ebo can do something that most
radio telescopes can't it can transmit
famously in 1974 it beamed the Arecibo
message out to the stars but there are
also some more practical uses for
sending big pulses of energy into space
radar Arecibo can bounce radar signals
off planets asteroids and well anything
nearby in the solar system and it can
build up clear pictures of what is out
there in the dark the advantage of using
the radar imaging is you can actually
see the
shape much better compared to the
optical imaging we can actually see even
boulders and surface if they are close
enough if it looks like a bone or if it
looks like a sweet potato the estrin
transmitter is a high power transfer
that works at 23 80 megahertz of
frequency that's the s-band the whole
transmitters of megawatt of power this
transmitter produces a beam of power and
if you put your hand right through it
you could get burned
we mostly observe near-earth asteroids
when you asteroids are found the orbit
is not very well defined yet the main
thing that we can do is really enhance
the orbit information transmit a signal
and when it hits a moving object the
wavelengths of the signal changes
depending on if the asteroid is moving
towards the observer or away from the
observer and that way we can actually
get an estimate two millimeters per
second of the velocity of the asteroid
when new asteroids are found the
distance can be determined to hundreds
of meters even tens of meters so we can
get very accurate information of where
the asteroid will be from now to decade
forward or even a century forward
asteroid Apophis the preliminary orbit
information showed that it actually
might hit the earth after it was
observed in radar they could determine
that it will go super close
it will probably disturb some of the
satellites that are there are orbiting
Earth but it doesn't hit the earth and
that's very important to know because
now we know that we don't have to send
Bruce Willis to deflect the asteroid out
of all natural catastrophes impacts are
the one thing that we can actually avoid
so earthquakes volcanoes they just
happen we can actually help them but if
we can observe an asteroid early enough
we have opportunity to deflect it thank
you so much to everyone at the Arecibo
Observatory if you'd like to know more
about them and their discoveries pull
down the description for lots of links
and you want to see behind the scenes on
this video then Matt who is on camera
has been taking a load of footage and
has put it together for the second
channel